No federal bureaucrat played a
bigger role in 20th century law
enforcement than J. Edgar Hoover,
who served as the head of the FBI
and its predecessor agency for
half a century.
Hoover oversaw crackdowns on
everything from real and imagined
communists, and the first red scare
of the 1920s and its sequel
in the 1950s, staged
high profile shootouts with public
enemies like John Dillinger and
Baby Face Nelson in the 1930s,
surveilled Nazi and Axis
sympathizers during World War II,
infiltrated the Ku Klux Klan, and
pursued extralegal operations
against civil rights leaders and
anti-war protesters in the 1960s.
His personal vendetta against Martin
Luther King Jr.
led to one of the most shameful
incidents in FBI history.
When the bureau sent an anonymous
letter to King shortly before
he was to receive the Nobel Peace
Prize, encouraging him to commit
suicide or be exposed
as a serial philanderer.
Hoover is the subject of Yale
historian Beverly Gage's new
biography, "G-man:
J. Edgar Hoover and the Making of
the American Century." Gage seeks
to complicate and flesh out the life
and legacy of Hoover, who is rightly
notorious for often brushing
aside constitutional limits on
state power.
Like so much police tape at a crime
site, Yet she points out
that he opposed the internment of
Japanese-Americans during World War
I, undermined Senator Joe
McCarthy's overwrought
anti-communist witch hunts and
refused to do political surveillance
for Richard Nixon, inadvertently
leading to the bungled Watergate
break-ins and the 37th
president's fall from grace.
"I shall resign the presidency
effective at noon tomorrow.".
To understand Hoover in all his
complexity, including his much
whispered about personal
relationship with his FBI colleague
Clyde Tolson, is to understand
the moral ambiguities of the country
he served, Gage tells Reason,
as well as to understand the promise
and limits of constitutional
government in an open society.
Beverly Gage.
Thanks for talking to Reason.
Thanks for having me.
Let's start with the elevator pitch
for "G-man: J. Edgar Hoover
and the Making of the American
Century." What, what?
How how do you summarize this book,
how do you pitch it to people
who should be interested in reading
it?
Well, it's been 30 years almost
since the last real crop of
Hoover biographies.
So part of the goal is just
to have a chance to look at all of
the records, all of the new history,
all of the new ways of thinking that
have come out over these decades.
But I guess I had two goals in mind.
One is to get away from what
I think is a little bit of our
caricature of Hoover as
this kind of one dimensional
villain, this figure who
stood outside of American politics,
manipulating everyone and actually
bring him back into
kind of a central part of the
story of the 20th century.
And then also to situate him in
a couple of political traditions
that we don't often think of as
going together in our own moment.
One is a kind of progressive,
good government expert
bureaucrat tradition, and the other
is a kind of deep social
conservatism.
And then think about the ways that
those two fit together in his life
and then shaped a lot of the 20th
century.
Can you dilate on
that a little bit? Because this is
something at Reason.
We tend to take a fairly
dark view of the progressive period,
partly because it was
so socially conservative and
reactionary.
You know, when you think about
things like alcohol prohibition,
you know, on the one hand,
the progressives were pushing for
women's rights in certain areas
and in other ways they were trying
to kind of control female sexuality
and new and emboldened ways.
Certainly with immigration, there
was a progressive fixation
on purity and cleanliness
that led to a lot of anti
anti-immigrant sentiment
and whatnot. So talk a
little bit about Hoover.
You know, as he emerges because he
was born, what in what
year was he born again?
So he was born 1895,
and he really came of age then
in the progressive era and entered
government in 1917
and sort of the peak year
of progressivism in many ways.
Which is amazing just, I'm sorry to
interupt, I mean, it's
it is amazing when you look at the
you know, I mean, it would
be as if Babe Ruth was still
playing baseball in
the early seventies or something,
you know, just that span.
And I want to talk with you a little
bit about, you know, that term in
your subtitle, "The American
Century." But
so Hoover is growing up.
He's he's a Washington, D.C.,
hometown guy.
What does it mean to be growing up
in the early 1900s?